municipal year it's nice to see some new
faces
and some older faces i'm not going to
say old because leaders of my age don't
say that word so uh
yep um
not expecting um a fire alarm at all so
um should the alarm sound please make
your way out of the building i think the
nearest fire exit is
just that away
um
and i'm going to ask alex to start
recording
are we off okay
um
so i've had apologies from councillor
dagnall and councillor bennett i don't
know if there are any more apologies
oh thank you
and the first item on the agenda is to
um note the membership of the committee
um
is that item noted
yeah thank you
and has everybody had a chance to have a
look through the terms of reference
for the committee and are there any
comments at all on that
um are there any declarations of
interest at all
do we have to declare for a school
governor i think we're all school
governors
so um yeah i think
i think that's given a given really so
but thanks anyway we don't have to
declare it no it's uh those are also
usually in your register of interest
anyway it's only if you had an
additional interest all right perfect
just wanted to check thank you okay and
i'm not aware of any questions from the
public
alex that okay uh none of being received
okay
and the next items we have minutes of
the meetings held on the 9th of february
2022
and the 15th of march is everybody happy
to accept those as a true record
yeah yeah thank you
okay i think because we've got some new
newer faces here um
would it be okay if we go around and
just make some quick introductions
before we start the meeting so
my name is denise weston and i
i'm a broadhead's ward councillor and i
chair this committee
is
i'm michael welton uh i am an autry
award counselor and uh
for what it's worth deputy leader of the
green group for what it's worth in a
four-person group
i'm councillor graham whittam and i
represent david hume westward
my name is fianna hornby and i represent
ghost hill ward
good evening i'm jill mcgregor i'm the
corporate director for children's
services here in trafford
thank you um i'm councillor new adele
and i represent bucklow which is
parsington carrington and sale west and
i'm the lead member for education
good evening everyone karen samples
director of education for trafford
what's on
hi sue maitland a counsellor for david
hume west with graeme and karina
i'm amy white counselor in broad heath
i'm michael wetton i'm a councillor for
bowdoin ward and i'm chair of the health
scrutiny committee so ex official
non-voting member of this committee
[Music]
i'm alexander murray and i'm a
governance officer
hi i'm simon hughes um i'll be
supporting this committee in the future
um
governance officer as well
thank you everybody and welcome simon i
hope we don't give you too much uh
trouble in the future
um
can we move on to item seven on your
agenda and that's the ofsted um
monitoring update and is that jill
thank you
thank you colleagues um obviously um
what we were wanting to do was to report
on our um improvement activity and
recognize that that's an ongoing um
process
and specifically to focus on the
off-step monitoring visit that took
place in march
um it probably feels like it's a long
time coming this report and it is in in
a number of ways but not least because
we were unable to um publish the report
or share the findings in advance of
the pre-election period so we didn't
actually receive the report
until the 6th of may
i think there are some things that
i hope that the committee would notice
and recognize as being significant
um so not least that um the inspection
team did say
that they
had found that services for children in
trafford had improved
the focus for the monitoring visit was
our children in care
they were really clear this as a
leadership team and in terms of the
performance management and monitoring
arrangements that there was a clear line
of sight in terms of what practice
looked like on the ground what we needed
to do in terms of improving practice and
they did identify some areas where they
could see impact
two of the things that i think it's
important to note is that they did
recognize the impact of covid and and
trying to improve services whilst
living with covid in a pandemic and they
recognize that that did have a
detrimental impact in terms of some of
our improvement activity
the other area that the inspection team
were really clear
about having an impact on our progress
was some of the turnover and some of the
impact of the instability in the
workforce
um
as i've said in terms of leadership they
they were really clear that the
self-view that we had was accurate
and that we had appropriate plans in
place
the inspection team were also clear that
the quality of assessments for a number
of our children was improving they were
particularly pleased to see
how we were using our child impact
chronologies
and i'm sure some of you on this
committee will remember that
using chronologies understanding
children's histories has been a
significant challenge for us but they
could see we'd adopted a new approach
and that that was having benefit
there were some areas such as our work
to discharge placements with parents
orders so care orders where children are
living at home with parents we've seen a
12 reduction in that so that's a real
positive and i know that's been an area
of interest for corporate parenting
board
where ofsted raised some some challenge
and we agreed with that was particularly
in relation to the quality of planning
so saying assessments are improving your
understanding of what's happening for
children is improving but how that
translates into meaningful plans
and they felt was an area that we needed
to do more work in and we would agree
with that
what i hope the report outlines as well
is some of the areas that we've
continued to progress and continue to
work on
and i think the first area that i would
like to highlight is workforce stability
that continues to be our biggest single
priority because actually
if you have instability in the workforce
your improvement activity it's almost
like one step forward two steps back
um pleasingly though we are seeing some
um reduction in terms of turnover
we have seen a slight um decrease in
terms of the number of agency staff that
we are using
as a service we're working very hard not
to use the term agency and talk about
interim staff because actually
regardless of whether you've got a
permanent contract or an interim
contract
these staff and practitioners are
delivering services to our children and
families
we have included all of our interim
staff in our workforce development plans
and the training programs that we're
putting in place
we're seeing some benefits from that are
um interim staff and i do have to remind
myself to use that term
um
62 of those staff have been with us for
six months or more so we're seeing a
reduction in terms of
that churn and turn over as well
we've continued to work on our quality
of practice through our ambitions plan
um and we are absolutely seeing that
reflected in our audit activity as well
and we've seen an absolute increase in
terms of the number of case file audits
the number of pieces of work that we're
looking at that both the leadership team
and the managers that are influencing
that work would see as good or requires
improvement and reduction in inadequate
um
i guess in terms of it
there is a number of details in the
report and what we really wanted to do
was open up a discussion and questions
in terms of the
the position that we're at
just for committee to note that we're
currently in the throes of
preparing for our next monitoring visit
and
we will have a team of two inspectors
on site with us on tuesday and wednesday
next week um
so forgive me if i i seem a bit vague
because i've got my head into that next
period of what they're going to be
looking at but happy to answer any
questions
thanks jill can i just say particularly
for new members please don't be
frightened to ask a question there's no
such thing as a silly question jill
loves questions um
but please don't be afraid to ask i've
just asked that if you want to ask
anything if you just raise your hand and
do so through the chair
thank you
okay so i'm going to start with
councillor maitland please
thanks jill for that um
with regards to the agency staff and the
ones that have been with you for
over six months
is there any sort of indication that
they would be interested in a permanent
contract at all or going through the
selection
process
we have actually had a small number of
agency staff who have converted to
permanent contracts we've currently got
an agency practice manager who's applied
for a permanent head of service job
we've had i think it's three social
workers
one of the things that we've got as an
ongoing basis is dedicated sessions with
those interim staff to
talk about the benefits of having
permanent employment
one of the challenges around that is
obviously cost of living crisis so if
you're getting paid more
being an agency worker of staff
and i guess because a number of our
agency staff are quite young i know at
23 i didn't see the benefits of having a
pension whereas actually that is one of
the real selling points for as well as
the the offer in the permanency
we're having to recognize that
increasingly and not least as a
consequence of the pandemic i think and
people having greater flexibility in how
they work that people are making choices
in terms of the type and nature of the
work that they want so we're doing a lot
of work to try and convert to permanent
if that's appropriate
we are also recognizing that we're
likely to have a mixed economy of
workforce so some people that will be
permanent some people that will be
interim for the right reasons because
they like the variety
we're also doing a lot of work on a gm
basis and a northwest basis to try and
look at whether we can establish a
not-for-profit
um agency in terms of it
and i guess it links to one of the other
items in terms of the care review and
that focus on actually how can we
turn that around how can we build an
experience
so i can i think in in the report it
does detail some of the numbers that
have converted so small numbers but we
are making a targeted effort but equally
looking at how we build instability
within those interim staff
thanks for that jill can i just ask a
question quick question are we
competitive um in comparison to other
boroughs in the salaries that we offer
permanent staff
it's one of those things that's a
constant roundabout
counselor weston and
i think you will recall that previously
we have applied a market factor
supplement to some of the posts where we
had greatest movements
and we're in the process of
re-benchmarking and as soon as one local
authority does something somewhere else
somewhere else does something else
and
so
i think we're holding our own
one of the things that's really
interesting is pay is no longer the
biggest reason in terms of what why
people are leaving and equally and the
environment and the offer is no longer
the biggest reason why people are
leaving but some of the examples where
we've had some of that
turnover for example somebody that
very committed we very much wanted them
to stay with us and they've needed to
move to another part of the country to
look after elderly relatives for example
so
we constantly analyze we've tried to
turn on its head and we are again seeing
some success
not to have exit interviews but to have
stay interviews to talk to people in
advance
and to think about what we can do on an
individual basis
um
but
some of the competition in terms of the
rates of agency pay 45 pounds an hour we
can't compete with that so it's more
important that we create the environment
and the conditions that will support
practitioners to be with us
and
interestingly we had somebody who went
over the border
again an agency member of staff
they've come back
to us because they think well yes i can
get more across
the border but actually how i'm looked
after how i'm supported the value base
is much
stronger that's great thanks jill
councillor acton
yeah thanks for
uh
the report and um i think
it's pleasing to know that ofsted um you
know recognizing improvements
uh throughout the children's services
and
um
and that's really to be welcomed
and i do i do as you know jill as i sit
on the court corporate parenting board
and it's good to see that
um
that there's a recognition that the
parent
corporate parenting board is is
challenging
um
and that
uh
it is working really well
in terms of that challenge
um
i think i know i know linda's on that
board and i think we
we do get good reports now don't we
and i think that's
to be welcome um i just pick up on on
one of the paragraphs and that's um
only half of all children in care attend
their review meetings in person
this means that children are not always
able to contribute directly to
um
these important meetings about them
um
and i
and obviously
it remains an area for development um so
i just wonder what those areas of
development is because
it is crucial really um
in in terms of the lives of those
children that they are there and they
can represent themselves with with
support
um and i know that work is going on but
i just like some feedback
feedback on that
so great question counselor acton and i
think the start point for that
development work is talking to our
children and young people why don't you
come to your meetings what would make it
more
um
interesting for you who do you want
there
so in some parts of the service we have
developed different ways of holding
those meetings so thinking about who do
you want to come to your meeting where
do you want the meeting to be what do
you want that to look like because i
think it's really important that
you know our children and young people
feel in in charge of the plans that are
for them
we're strengthening the role of the iro
so the independent reviewing officers
and one of the areas that is starting to
improve is where they have
a meeting with the young person the
child in advance of the meeting
so that they can
ask some of those questions but equally
to build up that confidence to come to
meetings
we're working with our
children in care council and our
aftercare forum to tease out some of
those questions and what that looks like
for some young people um it's
appropriate to use an advocate as well
to speak um for them on their behalf
it's an area where we're literally
monitoring in terms of um the
performance because actually
it's so important that we do get that
right
so there's a number of different points
in in different parts of the service in
terms of of trying to raise that figure
one of the things that we have
challenged and drilled down is
previously our reporting was saying that
our young people attended or contributed
so we said no we need to know are they
coming
and what does a contribution mean so
actually even understanding what the
performance how many of our children and
young people
come to their meetings
and obviously working with the people
that are caring for them and looking
after them whether that's our foster
carers or whether it is their own
parents to say what would make this
easier what will make this more
comfortable
one of the other things that we're doing
is really taking the learning from the
pandemic so for some people actually
doing things remotely or through
an app or on your phone feels more
comfortable for other people like me
like to talk a lot and want to be there
so i don't think it's a single action i
think it's an area of dedicated focus
that we're working on
and the other point that would come back
to counselor acton is you you comment
about corporate parenting and i think it
is really pleasing to see that
recognized and i think you will recall
when i first started here and we didn't
even have a scorecard or performance
information or regular reports saying
what was happening so it is pleasing
that that challenge and those
developments have been recognized
thanks jim council hornbit did you have
a question thank you um i noted and you
also mentioned the idea of developing a
bespoke
northwest not-for-profit agency and i
really welcome that and it seems like
such a great idea to tackle staff
shortages where is that kind of up to at
the moment
so where that's up to is all 23 local
authorities in the northwest have signed
up to that scoping work the work's being
led by rural
council
and we've just finished the first phase
of that to see if it does look like
it'll be viable and local authorities
have been asked to contribute
information and provide details of their
current staffing and retention and we're
just awaiting the report to recommend we
move to the next stage with it
okay brilliant thank you
thanks jill you have a question yeah
councillor welton
thank you um i was interested in the
comparative uh work you were doing on on
employees conditions and salary and
things like that i'm just wondering is
there are there any
boroughs or other councils that are
doing particularly well
um
you know in terms of retention of staff
and uh you know and can we learn from
them are we are we are we talking to
them about best practice and all that
kind of thing i think in terms of
greater manchester it's something like
209 social work vacancies within the
children's space so
um
i think everywhere is struggling i think
it's a national issue
what our agency supplier would say is
that actually in trafford we're holding
our own one of the reasons that they
would say that we're holding our own is
we talk to them regularly about what we
need
our recruitment campaign is a little bit
of a slow burn but we are seeing a
constant drip drip in terms of people
coming to us so things like the
workforce development offer
using testimonials so i think we're
doing okay but our proportion of
permanent staff to agency staff is
higher than i would want
we have linked into local authorities
outside of greater manchester as well
sunderland being one of the um really
standout examples so they'd gone from a
40 plus percent agency um rate to
under 10 agency rate
finance and incentive was a big part of
their initial um approach as was
rebranding
so we we all looking elsewhere but it is
a real national issue
counsellor wetton
thank you um i
can ask just
two or three questions about the
workforce stability and particularly the
agency used
so i wondered what what's the highest
level of seniority that you're covering
with
agency staff
um
i'm also interested to know the the
shortest
period that you would
use an agency worker for
um
because i'm what what i'm
uh interested in knowing there is about
the
the continuity and in fact continuity of
um
appearances uh particularly with
um the younger people because i seem to
remember from a
um
a past life on this council
they one of the things that the young
people feed back is the
um
they don't like the fact that um there's
so much churn on the workforce that they
meet
um they don't get enough continuity
going with
um
with the you know the staff that they're
actually meeting so bit of a garbage mix
of questions there but be interesting to
know what you take is on that
so absolutely agree with all young
people in your question the the the
thing that makes the biggest difference
to our quality of practice and to
whether we can make a difference to our
children young people and families is
having that consistency and having trust
and um
having meaningful relationships so
that's one of the reasons why is the
biggest priority for us to to stabilize
the workforce
our children and young people and our
children in care counselling our have to
care for them absolutely say i want
somebody that's going to stick with us i
want some i want to tell my story once
i want to know that you're there for me
and i don't want to have to keep
building new relationships
one of the things that was pleasing in
this
monitoring visit was that ofsted did see
some real endeavors and some real
attempts by some of our practitioners to
go above and beyond to build that trust
and to mitigate against where there's
been changes of worker
and
unfortunately
ultimately we cannot um compel people to
stay with us we can support we can
encourage we can be as attractive try
and create the right conditions for for
people to want to work with us
what we do need to get better at though
is how we end things properly how people
say goodbye and that is one of the the
downsides when we have needed to use
interim staff so i think one of your
questions was what's the shortest period
an agency member of staff can give a
week two weeks a day's notice in terms
of it and that is some of what's
experienced not just here but nationally
it's really important that how somebody
hands over a piece of work that they're
already doing how somebody says goodbye
to a child or family that they get that
right so we're working really hard in
terms of these are the expectations this
is how you do say goodbye to try and
mitigate against that
um in terms of the the highest level in
terms of of management
we do have some interim heads of service
at the moment
and
we've got a permanent head of service
for our vulnerable adolescent service
starting on monday which is really
pleasing so they'll walk straight into
the inspection where possible service
area is is an area of focus
and
we do have two other um interim heads of
service
one we've just been out to permanent
recruitment for and have have not been
successful in getting the pool and the
caliber of candidates that we would want
um and the other area we're waiting
until um
slightly further into the autumn term
before we go back out because actually
trying to recruit over the summer period
can be quite challenging but that's the
highest level i've got at the moment
okay thank you for may just come back in
with another quick question
in in your forecasting your uh for the
budget
uh you're you're forecasting your staff
costs presumably you're forecasting the
use of agency
staff
absolutely and at the moment some of my
vacancy rates are
reducing the overspend on placements
rather than the other way around but
it's a point that's really well made
obviously it's not cost effective to pay
a higher rate
for practitioners managers to do the
same role and responsibility as somebody
else and ultimately
your first question
about how can you build trusting
relationships what difference does that
make to children and families is right
we do want people that are consistent
that are committed
and
we want to be able to develop all our
workforce those traffic is the employer
of choice
thanks jill and councillor blackburn
thank you
could i just ask jill
specific period of time whereby an
interim member of staff
has to
get the opportunity for an interview for
a permanent position or can somebody
being an interim
employee
for
whenever for however long
they can be an interim employee for
however long but what we're trying to do
is as we recruit on a permanent basis um
reduce the number of agency staff so
it's not like we we're going
supernumerary
one of the um
incentivizations that we're trying to
look at is actually to offer fixed term
contracts rather than agency contracts
to say this is how long we think you
will be needed for and this is how long
we want you to commit for again to
reduce some of the impact on our
children and families
so normally a contract we'd be looking
at agency use for about three to six
months and that's based on the average
time that it takes to recruit
permanently because if somebody's got a
three-month notice period to give for
example
so the average recruitment episode is
about three to six months but that
intention of
having more permanent staff and as they
come on board
exiting out and agency stuff that sounds
terrible does that but that is
what we are um progressing so we map all
of that out so
over the next eight weeks we've got i
think it's 16 new members of staff that
are going to be starting we've mapped
against which vacancies
and they are going against and whether
that does mean we can reduce some of our
numbers of agency staff
thank you everybody for your questions
thank you jill for your ever
comprehensive responses and
it's pleasing to see that improvements
are being made and reassuring for us all
i think um
so with that um i'm going to hand over
to jill again um
and we're moving on to the social care
review which does obviously impact um
our children's services
thanks it almost feels like the three
items that i've got fit neatly together
don't they so one is about our position
statement which is what we've just been
talking about in terms of the monitoring
visit
and the next item is
the care review
and colleagues will be aware that there
has been a national review of all
children's services
um that's been undertaken by josh
mcallister
and josh mcallister by background is a
teacher which i find quite interesting
in terms of review of um children's
services
um i think it's really important um
to
recognize that at this moment in time
the review is just making
recommendations
they're not
the government hasn't yet committed to
whether they will accept the
recommendations or indeed whether
they will adopt any of them or all of
them
the context to the review is included in
the slide deck that's been shared with
you and that context is about increasing
pressures
on children's services
so an increase in demand increase in
numbers of early help assessments
contacts referrals received increasing
and safeguarding referrals
and
some of what the review does
is
talk about children's social care
nationally as being a 30 year old jenga
tower held together with sellotape
which
within the context of recruitment
retention feels slightly challenging
specific focus on the data in terms of
high numbers of section 47 enquiries
that don't go on to children being on
child protection plans
the rising cost of
caring for children the number of
children in care the financial aspects
of that and a decrease in foster carers
and adopters
and within the slide pack i think um
slide seven
um
helpfully and i do choose my words with
care there and
show what josh is in the review team's
um thoughts of what the system looked
like um so
reduction in terms of early help some of
the um contextual factors like um
increase in terms of cost of living
poverty
but very much um saying that there was a
mindset that wasn't right about
helping people as early as possible as
they could
the
the review came up with something like
87 recommendations which is a phenomenal
amount of recommendations and on slides
13 and 14 what we've tried to do is
group them into some of the key areas
you'll see that one of the things that's
really very much recommended is the
concept of family help so rather than
talking about early help or whether um
children and families need to help us
child in need but bringing together
if people need help they need it at the
time that they do and we should be
intervening as early as possible
so it promotes the notion of the
creation of dedicated family help teams
that bring together things that
previously sat in early help and
previously sat in child in need
running alongside that the review makes
recommendations about the child
protection system i'm very much saying
that your family help arrangement should
be the key support for children and
families and where there is a
safeguarding need an experienced child
protection practitioner should work
alongside
and and the review defines that
experience as somebody as having five
years experience and having completed
the early career framework to be an
expert
what's really interesting about that i
think is that the average time that um
somebody spends as a children and family
social worker is seven years now so that
feels slightly out of kilter to me
big focus in terms of extra familial
harms such as exploitation and how
actually thinking about
multi-disciplinary
responses to that will will help
real focus on transforming care not just
in terms of
the type of places where our children
live
so trying to turn around the
the um
reliance on external placements external
foster care has increased the numbers
but introduces the notion that we should
have regional care cooperatives to
source and find placements
raising the status of family-based care
through family networks and from a
principled point of view i think you you
wouldn't disagree with that that
actually wherever it's safe for children
and young people to live and grow you
would want that to be within their
families even if it's extended family
networks
there's a number of recommendations
around um care experience one of the
things
that the review is advocating is um
introducing
making care experience a protected
characteristic
and i'd be really interested to know
what all young people think about that
because there's obviously some positives
to that
but there's the potential of
stigmatization as a consequence around
that
lots of recommendations around workforce
this notion of we have to do something
different and to reduce reliance on
agency staff
but i'm not sure that how they marry up
gets to the the heart of what we need to
do
so really what we wanted to do was raise
the awareness of the the care review and
some of the
issues that are being raised such as um
not having iros to independently review
children's plans but saying advocates
should be able to do that
my own professional view would be
advocacy is very different from
reviewing a plan in terms of of that
challenge
we have included as well some of the
implications for
us here in trafford but i would be
really keen for the committee to
recognize that
the majority of the recommendations
haven't yet been enacted and would
require changes to primary legislation
if the 87 recommendations did get
adopted it would be as significant as
for example the changes that we've seen
in adult social care and health arena
happy to take any questions on it and
appreciate there's an awful lot of
information there this is the condensed
slide deck um i would like to add as
well
thanks jill and councillor blackburn
um the removal of the iro role that
concerns me because the iros um are
obviously there not just to
ensure that the the the child is looked
after but it's ensuring that the council
are doing what they should be doing
and
if
the recommendations are agreed upon does
that mean that
all the recommendations will then
be sort of in in law and every every one
of them will either be taken up or or
not so
so that's a really good example council
blackburn and i agree with you i think
the clue's in the title isn't it
independent reviewing officers so whilst
they happen to be employed by the local
authority in legislation in the care
planning regulations and they are
charged to be independent so they have
that unique role of both holding the
local authority to account and
championing and making sure that we have
the right plans for our children and
young people in place
so that's an example where primary
legislation will need to be
enacted in order to make that change
so some things could be adopted by the
government and without making major
legislative changes other things would
require changes to legislation but i
agree with you i'm old enough to
remember when and team managers practice
managers were responsible for reviewing
children's plans for children looked
after
and one of the reasons why we got the
iro handbook was because that didn't
happen as robustly as we would want
there was drift and delay in planning
for children
and
they they hold a very unique role
i think some of the thinking behind that
recommendation was they're qualified
social workers we need more social
workers would that be a way of doing it
i think that's one of the more
controversial aspects
but i also just ask um
the
talking about the um
[Music]
that you know more support on them you
know sort of a
a multi uh
um disciplinary level um is is that
would that be similar to when we have
the stronger families programme
we still have the stronger families
program and it's really interesting that
you ask about that because one of the
things that we're doing in phase two of
our redesign
is looking at how we can transform or
really help hopes to be family hoops
which is at the center of the
the concept of family help and we're
also in the process of reviewing our
intensive family support team
arrangements and what we're all looking
at is having a multi-disciplinary
approach to that
recognizing that
in order to improve outcomes and be
helpful for our children we need to be
helpful to the adults that look after
them so if somebody's experiencing
domestic abuse if somebody's got poor
mental health as an adult if they're
experiencing difficulties
um in terms of their own life
experiences if we're not helpful to the
adults we won't be helpful to our
children
so we are looking at how we can
implement a model of multidisciplinary
working arrangements
we have already made some changes to our
front door arrangements so the first
response team and we have um somebody
that trained to be
an independent independent domestic
violence
advisor in the front door we have an
education specialist
we have um
a health visiting
or somebody from mft that has health led
and support in in terms of it
it's right that you need different
skills to offer different sorts of help
so we are really looking at that
and and hopefully in the very near
future we'll be having a theory of
change session
around how we develop our our family
hubs as well
thank you
thanks jill uh councilloracton
thanks chair
um yeah thanks for bringing this report
it is interesting uh
obviously
this reform programme
will require
2.6 billion of new spending over
four years
um
but it recognizes that this might not
happen
and
it goes on to say and we already seeing
some re-badging of existing cash
example strengthening families money
seen as part of this investment
so really they're going to pinch
money off different parts of his is
providing
services already and
um without the extra resource
um
would this still go ahead
i think that's a really challenging
question for me to answer in a political
way
but i think the reality is that the
review is saying the system needs major
reform
in order to achieve the full extent of
the intentions of the review it does
require significant investment
the strengthening families money that
councillor blackburn and yourself
mentioned is already a grant that the
local authority receives
and they are saying some of the money is
within the system and you need to think
about how you use it
as always with all of these major
reviews the devil's in the detail isn't
it and it will be interesting to see
what
does come forward in terms of of that
investment but i think the very scale of
the investment
is one of the challenges in terms of
what will get
enacted and what will become legislation
and i think if we go back to slide
number three
that shows um it's an annual thing that
that
the association of the directors of
children's services do that looks at
what the increase of demand is what that
means in terms of the numbers of
children and families that need our help
the analysis that's being attached to
that is you're not doing it strong
enough well enough early enough and if
you did that um you wouldn't need that
level of spend
i i think that's a slightly simplistic
analysis of what the data says
yeah so do i
councillor welt
thank you um yeah just
interested in the slide um regarding
data and technological solutions um
it says uh there's a huge scope for the
better use of data and technological
solutions in child protection but
obviously it's a very
people-focused enterprise so i mean my
mind's blank so i don't know if you've
got
any any ideas of what they're what
they're referring to
i mean one of the things and it links to
the next agenda item is in terms of how
information is shared and how different
agencies can
access
the information i'm old enough to
remember when the first integrated care
system which wasn't anything to do with
adults and health and it was to do with
joining up with systems and sharing
records for children
and so there is something that you know
um progressing or seeking that holy
grail before systems talk to each other
we could be more efficient
there's some elements around that
and there are some things that it it can
be hugely helpful to think about how we
maximize technology you know so that
question that counselor acton asked
earlier about
children going to their their reviews
actually kids are much more tech savvy
than than the likes of me
and clicking on apps and doing things so
there are some efficiencies
um
but if if one of the drives for the
review is to spend more time with people
i think the point's really well made you
know helping children and families in a
relational way involves conversations
doesn't it involve seeing people so
you would want
your systems to be as efficient as they
possibly could you would want to have
effective information sharing but
ultimately there's got to be a human to
human interaction as well
thanks jill and if there are no more
questions thank you there's a lot to
take in in that pack of uh slides so
thank you
and
what i would say is in terms of how the
review is structured because this is a
real summary high level of it it is
individual chapters so there's seven or
eight individual chapters so it is
something that people can go
back to and and pick over rather than
try and wade through
all of this in in one go and but just to
repeat again at this moment in time it's
just recommendations
and
i'm just thinking could there be a
chance that some of those
recommendations are adopted but not
others or
yeah yeah
i think without doubt they probably will
look at um reform of the safeguarding
arrangements so our trafford strategic
safeguarding partnership the
multi-agency safeguarding arrangements
clearly there's already a national drive
in in policy context for family hubs and
family help so that will continue to
flow whether it stays in the exact form
that it looks like and i think they're
genuinely interested in the placement
issue and how we can have better choice
and better matching of placements so
the recommendations about um
the regional care cooperatives is
probably something that might get some
traction
okay thanks jill
if we can move on to the next item which
is school funding and i believe karen
are you going to
send this to us thank you
yeah apologies this isn't my area of
expertise by any stretch of the
imagination but i'll do my best um so
unfortunately um we're not able to get a
representative representative from
finance tonight
um however um alex
helpfully sent the report to me today um
and what i'll do is i'll try and kind of
walk through the report and then pick up
any questions but i may have to take
them back with me to the team
and
clearly what the report seeks to do is
obviously um
talk people through the actual
allocation of funding that is available
to schools and just a little bit about
the national funding formula that the
the report refers to that's basically
the method that the government uses to
decide how much money every school gets
each year this is set out by government
but it's administered actually by the
local authorities so you've got some
flexibility then in how you apply that
for that for schools in our area
it was introduced actually back in 2018
um but there's been transitional
arrangements that um have have enabled
then local authorities to embed the
formula um but obviously all local
authorities now have to follow that that
formula and and and the way that the
funding is sort of allocated to schools
is obviously um a kind of a it's called
an orpu we call it it's an age-weighted
pupil unit
and that's allocated per
um
sector of education really so primary is
around
3750 pounds per pupil
and secondary is at least five thousand
pounds
um
and what the minimum there's also a
minimum funding guarantee that that
local authorities adopt as well and that
ensures then that there'll be a certain
amount per pupil funding each year so
schools can't go below that or equally
above it so there's kind of a threshold
to just
give a level of protection i think
around funding for schools but on top of
that basic
figure as well schools also
get additional funding and some of that
will be based on deprivation so where
they are in terms of their deprivation
indices some of it will be based on any
low priority that this uh
schools show so it might be
lower attainment in good level of
development in in the early years etc
um eal funding english is an additional
language there'll be additional funding
around that and also mobility so where
you've got schools with differing
numbers of children coming in and
leaving and some schools will have
greater mobility issues than others so
there's some funding attached to that
um
on top of that schools also get lump
sums so that lump sum is essentially
around 110 000 that's for primary
schools um and they'll also get some
additional premises funding
there's a growth funding grant that
comes in as well to the local authority
and that that's quite useful for us in
trafford just because we've seen such
huge rates of growth in terms of our
student population so where we've had to
ask schools to
maybe create bulge classes or expand etc
etc we can give them growth funding
we apply that normally on where we're
seeing cohorts of 15 plus students where
we're asking that the population to grow
so we can offer them the growth funding
that helps for them to employ a teacher
etc so that they can they can meet that
demand and meet that need and at the
moment our growth funding actually is
quite quite a healthy pot which is which
is good for for the local authority
um so that's kind of a little bit around
and the actual funding formula that's
that's applied to schools local
authorities get what's called the dsg
it's the dedicated schools grant and
that's divided into the three blocks so
you've got the schools block and that's
really where the local authority is
allocating the funding out to its
schools using the funding formula that's
been agreed we also get an early years
block as well that obviously helps to
support particularly our um early years
sector and schools with nursery classes
as well and then we have the high needs
block as well which covers off
everything around special educational
needs
and
so i've kind of talked you through the
schools block
also what you will see in the paper is
the role of the funding forum
so all local authorities are required to
have a funding forum and we have
representatives from from various kind
of uh parts of
the education sector maintain schools
academies uh we'll also have governor
representation we have an early years
representation
it might be that counselor new joins
that because certainly councillor carter
sat on that as well um and we also have
other non-school organizations as well
so trade union reps diocese etc etc and
the forum there really is around having
a consultative role although it is a you
know it's a public facing forum all of
the papers are there in the public
domain but there are situations where
they'll have decision-making powers as
well and because we have subgroups that
sit underneath that and they tend to
make recommendations to funding forum
which is then discussed and voted on and
so that's quite an important mechanism i
think for schools to to share some of
their thinking around financing for the
local authority to make decisions
just on top of that little bit around
funding for sen as well within schools
and obviously there's kind of three
three elements if you like to send
funding that comes into schools we've
got the element one which is that per
pupil weighting
unit figure that i've just shared with
you um but then there's what we call an
element to funding as well and it's what
we call the notional send funding
and again that's something that we
that's contributed out to schools uh
based on the number of children you know
with with scn
and that is round about a contribution
of around 6 000 per
pupil and then obviously when schools
need additional top-up funding so where
they're making requests for additional
funding
that may contribute then to any an
education health and care plan that's an
application that can be made and that
will come out of the high needs high
needs funding as well um so that's a
top-up that's that's applied for
um certainly when we look at
any additional top-up funding there is
an element at panel where we'll
scrutinize the use of the
notional sen budget as well to make sure
that schools are using it appropriately
and they can cost out how that's being
used
some of the other funding that our
schools get is obviously pupil premium
and the funding there is obviously it's
ring fenced you know schools are held to
account for the spending of their pupil
premium funding and that is around
raising the attainment of any
disadvantaged children and young people
and eligibility for that is is generally
around those that young people that have
been eligible for free school meals in
the last six years
um our family information service
support families in terms of eligible
eligibility criterion to support them
through making those applications as
well for the pupil premium pupil premium
is is really quite quite helpful for
schools it's it's rounding about 1 300
pounds per primary pupil it's around
nine thousand five hundred from uh nine
sorry nine thousand wishful thinking
955 pounds per pupil for secondary um
and then obviously there's an allocation
for our looked after children as well
and and previously looked after children
too now those children who are looked
after that funding comes directly into
the local authority whereas those
previously looked after and those that
are kind of um
previously in care that goes direct out
to schools
um we've also obviously had the
allocation of catch-up funding as well
that's been made available since covid
which again has been has been really
helpful i think for schools but again um
kind of ring fenced around the use of
tutoring and really aimed at enabling
children to catch up and
particularly in light of some of the
missed missed opportunities that they've
had over the last couple of years
um interestingly we've had the stats
results today
we've not got the complete indicative um
figures yet um but you know again i'm
sure some of that is being tested out
with schools about you know where that
sits along alongside their sats outcomes
and finally schools also get the pe
premium sports premium as well and and
the positive thing is that's been
continued as well which which is which
is great really for schools um and that
is very much earmarked around children
just being able to um access sports and
and you know high quality pe sports
provisioning schools
and that general sort of well-being and
just making sure um children continue to
to be well supported from a physical and
emotional point of view and again
schools are accountable for the spending
of sports premium too
um
the other uh part of the the paper sort
of shared some of the support that's
provided as well for our schools from
trafford finance team um it's a wide
range of support really around um
generally school budget planning pupil
premium etc etc and particularly around
nursery funding and obviously that
application of the the funding formula
policies and so on schools are required
also to
complete a consistent financial
reporting return and that really is
detailing the income and the expenditure
of schools so again our finance officers
will scrutinise and look at that and and
also the schools are also required to
complete you'll know this as governors
the school's financial value standard as
well which is a huge document that is
very much you know um
it's certainly a series of questions for
governing bodies to answer
and it is huge um but again that's about
providing uh the assurance really that
schools are meeting that basic standard
around you know really good
financial management and resource
management
um the local authority also supports
certainly in terms of uh training it
will support if we're having to open new
schools um you know everything around
amalgamations all of those sorts of
things that kind of factor into school
place planning um
a big part of their job is also looking
at attendance with the f40 group we are
one of the the f40 group which are the
lowest funded 40 authorities um in in
the country so again that that's a group
that continues to campaign for you know
fair funding and particularly in
education
and i think finally one of the most
important parts that the the finance
team do support is where schools are
setting a deficit budget as well
and obviously you know and there is a
requirement if you like for schools to
produce a plan which will bring their
budget back in line and back in balance
so that's something that the local
authority not only scrutinizes but
support schools with as well and in
helping them manage to to get to a more
positive position
so i think that that's a whistle-stop
tour and hopefully i've i've helped but
as i say i will take back any questions
that i can't answer
thank you does anybody have any
questions okay counsellor written please
yeah just wonder if we if we know how
many schools have indicated that we'll
be able to
have a balanced budget yeah i think the
report said i think we've got two
schools at the moment with a a deficit
recovery plan in place
um and
you know schools are continuing to
share the pressures particularly brought
brought on by covey just that increased
use of supply staff etc a bit like what
jill was talking about with children's
social care unfortunately you know some
of the staffing issues is is presenting
some additional pressures as well um
things like rates obviously increases in
terms of um staff
just staff pay salary some of the
national insurance contributions etc etc
so you know there will absolutely
continue to be pressures one one
interesting thing for for local
authorities you know a lot a lot the
vast majority of our schools are also
carrying some good surpluses as well um
and we we always kind of keep an eye on
that we we generally apply a an eight
percent um surplus figure uh that we
allow schools to to carry forward it's
around five percent for secondary
schools and we don't claw that back if
they do go over the eight percent some i
believe some local authorities do we
don't do that um but what we do expect
is for schools to articulate how those
surpluses will be are being accounted
for and you know what what they're
saving up for really because it is about
spending the money on the here and now
for the children and young people in
their care
so at the minute the deficit budgets are
okay but i think it's certainly
something that we'll have to continue to
watch
i think we could because i think it
probably when the paper is circulated we
didn't have the budget plans
all received back that would be good i
think if they can't i think it's the end
of june wasn't it yeah the deadline so
yeah committee could get an update on
whether in any schools more schools have
indicated that they won't have a
balanced budget
one one thing that we do do and and
councillor new attended it actually the
other day we have the um the jnc which
is a meeting with our trade union
representatives and that's something we
always share we always report on is you
know the financial positions or any
schools struggling so again that's
something that you know maybe if i don't
get the opportunity to share it on a
regular basis hopefully counseling you
might be able to report that as well
that'd be really helpful i mean i think
given the increases in just in
the day-to-day
heating our schools lighting our schools
energy costs i think we're going to find
a lot more schools
in that predicament aren't we but
council blackburn if you have any
questions um could ask please the the
two schools that have got the license
deficit
how long
um are they given in order to
overcome the deficits i think i think we
look at a three-year deficit recovery
plan sometimes it does go to to a longer
length of time something it has been
five years um for you know in the past
but we we try to work on a three-year
plan to bring it back online and
essentially it's a it's the case that
you know the big
i suppose there's two two items really
which help support it unfortunately some
of that is looking at staffing
structures and whether we can do
anything to
unfortunately it does tend to make them
very very lean but also opportunities
for general for generating income
because that sometimes is also the only
way uh to bring balances online and
actually going back to the deficit um
conversation we we have covered because
we a lot of schools had to close their
out-of-school provision or their holiday
provision or whatever
that's what they relied on to generate
income and that's where they've suffered
heavy heavy losses so that also will
have contributed to some of the
financial pressures i think so once we
get those back online that might see
schools recovering a little bit quicker
a bit better
i also ask um
are we confident that the governing
body's skills matrix is is sort of up to
speed in order that they can
obviously support the the head teachers
and
you know staff with dealing with you
know with the
with the deficits
that's a that's a really good question
and certainly
um through governor training you know
that that's the message that is being
shared around making sure the skills
matrix is complete that you've got the
right people who can give that level of
scrutiny and business support i think
another important element though it will
be captured through the school's
financial value standards as well
because you know it will be
um scrutinized through that and also
through audit you know a lot of schools
have audits we we have a you know a
timeline for every school to receive an
audit and actually if it's a local
authority we're a little bit concerned
about things we could also request audit
to go in and that is a really rigorous
tool to ensure that you know that the
right level of expertise is there across
the across the governing body the other
bit ofsted will also check it out too
and i think the question will be will be
shared through an inspection just to
make sure that that's kind of picked up
in the quality of leadership and
management and governance in the school
okay thank you very much
thanks karen well for a report you
hadn't prepared you gave us a very very
comprehensive
review of it so thank you
and if we can move on to the next item
which is um
electively home educated
thank you
hopefully the slideshow will come up
shortly
um
i don't know whether it's gone to sleep
as well alex
if not i can
i'll carry on talking i'll carry on
talking throughout it's coming on slowly
but surely
so hopefully you can you can see that
okay so um
basically just uh again just a reminder
of what the definition of elective home
education is
you know it is it is a choice for
parents to provide education for their
children at home instead of sending them
to school full-time
parents can use private tutors as part
of their um home education as well but
there's no requirement to do so
and again
you know this is i think what we do try
to articulate parents as well
when they are making these choices is to
be really clear about what it means so
taking on that financial responsibility
as well um particularly when it comes to
things like exams and things like that
you know children can sit exams through
the private route but families will have
to to finance that themselves
and so that's that's just quickly the
the main definition
and we've established some principles
really that we try to apply in trafford
and essentially what we do know is
obviously all children are entitled to
an efficient full-time education but
equally parents may elect to educate the
only time that obviously there's a an
issue with that is whether they're
subject to a school attendance order so
where we have children who who have not
been attending school um and clearly
there are other um
systems in place if you like to to
manage school attendance
where a parent does notify the school in
writing that they are home educating and
they don't have to do that but where
they do and the majority do and the
school then has to take the child's name
off the register and they let us know so
we have an ehe inbox if you like in an
ehe form that we ask schools to to send
through to us
obviously what what we what we don't
want is schools actively seeking to
persuade parents that this is a good op
you know it's the right thing to do for
their children um or it's an opportunity
to avoid exclusion or because children
have got a poor attendance record you
know that is absolutely not acceptable
and and that would be classed as
off-roading or gaming and again that's
something that we're really clear up
with schools about
what we do have to do though is
obviously intervene where we feel that a
child isn't receiving a suitable
education and
i'll go on to that shortly but also we
also have a duty to safeguard all of our
children and again there are
steps that we do have in the process if
we do have concerns around safeguarding
of any child
with special educational needs in those
with an ehc plan they can still be home
educated so that is still an option for
parents
essentially
where the ehc plan does set out the send
provision that the child would receive
at home then we still have to arrange
that provision so if home is going to be
named on an ehc plan then we you know
clearly we have to arrange that that
provision is in place
obviously where the hc plan names the
school but but again
as the place where the child has their
education but the parent chooses to home
educate then again we have to make sure
that the provision is suitable according
to delivering the outcomes on the ehc
plan
and so in order to do that we need to
continue just like we would anyway
an annual review of the plan every year
to to check that it remains appropriate
and that it continues to to meet the
child's scnd needs
so what we do in trafford we provide
parents with a named contact uh so we
have um
sort of one and a half if you like ehe
officers in in trafford we've actually
expanded that because we only used to
have one um but our other one is all to
have all the roles so he's not actually
uh completely um
full-time in ehc but we do have a name
contact and essentially they are there
to advise and to support families just
basically really understanding some of
the philosophies around
ehe
they would ordinarily make contact as
well with
with parents of home educated children
at least on an annual basis because that
is about making sure that suitability of
education is provided
and you know again just being a really
good contact to make sure that parents
are advised supported in any way shape
or form that they require
we also obviously
interact with other parts of the system
too particularly if we are concerned
about children who we deem as missing
education because we're not convinced
the suitability is there
um if we if we're worried that some
children are placed in unregistered
provisions or settings and any children
where we've got concerns around
vulnerabilities and their welfare so we
will have an interface with um first
responds for example the front door
with children social care with health
colleagues etc if we
we always ask for parental consent about
linking in with health colleagues
because very often that information is
parents don't want that to be shared so
we always have to it's done on a consent
basis
we also
make sure that there's training in place
around the legal aspects um for officers
as well particularly if they're having
contact with families maybe having to
visit families at home as well just
making sure that they are supported um
in terms of their their practice
um
we have to obviously make sure that
parents are given the right information
from the outset so we've got a positive
relationship with our families but again
just to to reiterate
families are under no obligation to
accept that support or advice from the
local authority but equally if they
refuse it doesn't mean that they're not
doing a good job and that the education
is is unsuitable
um and i think the other bit is also
recognising that there are lots of
methods that are employed to give a
suitable education so it might include
flexi schooling it might include some
attendance at college or an alternative
provision or tutoring so it isn't just
needing to always be a child at home
all of the time
so
what we do when when a child we are
aware of a child being educated at home
we get a welcome pack and we send out a
questionnaire and the questionnaire
really is asking for information about
what the suitable suitability of
education is going to look like
parents don't have to follow the
national curriculum and they don't have
to follow the normal school day and the
patterns of the school day or the number
of hours that a child would
um would um be at school for but we do
ask them you know about the range of
subjects and topics that they're going
to be covering and what resources they
actually have at home what other
activities the child might be involved
in whether that's some physical
activities or going you know clubs that
they go to dance etc
we also ask about what kind of social
interaction the children will be
involved in at home so again if is it
just family and friends or are there
other groups that the children will be
involved in and who is actually
delivering on on that education as well
and are there other family members that
are going to be involved we also asked
how the work's going to be recorded and
how the parent is going to evaluate some
of the work that's carried out at home
and the kind of environment that's being
used whether that's outdoor indoor in
the home etc we also do try and see if
we can get some information from the
children themselves as well because
that's always always quite nice to hear
and then other things as well we we do
ask them as well as to why they've
chosen to home educate and that's that's
really important so we get a sense of
some of the system issues that that
might be there
if we're not happy that we've received
if either we don't get the form back or
the form comes back and we've got real
concerns about the suitability of
education then in the first instance we
do try and interact again with the
family and say you know try try and sort
of resolve any of those issues and try
and understand why they haven't got back
to us
however if it continues that again we've
got real concerns that the education
being provided is not deemed to be
suitable then it might be that we
referred the child to the children
missing education panel
and that's obviously when we try to
ensure the relevant processes are are
filled it might be that those children
will be allocated to play through the
fair access protocol um or also issuing
a school attendance order as well and so
for more formal processes are applied at
this stage
normally i mean
i was talking to the team actually this
afternoon and and
it's very very rare that we get to that
situation at all so which is which is
really really positive
in terms of how our ehe looks at the
moment because i think at the time of
writing the report it wasn't probably
the dashboard wasn't completely
up-to-date so
you may not be able to see these numbers
but hopefully you get a flavor if you
look the previous years ehe was 190 so
that's where we were at for the previous
year so you can see from that point
until now we've gone up to 208
which actually when you look at the
numbers the higher numbers of ehe
children particularly throughout covid
that's that's quite good we were aware i
know there's some work across gm
around the levels of ehe and certainly
the increase in he and some were
reporting some really significant
increases up to 50
increases so really quite staggering
numbers so actually that that's not a
bad not a bad place for us and what i do
know is i think we've we've closed round
about 93
cases as well so the vast majority of
those children have returned back to
education or they've actually gone out
of out of the area
you can see there that the main area
where we have the highest number of ehes
in the north so that's the red chunk
there
closely followed by the south
um so that's kind of from a locality we
do have it broken down into wards as
well and stretford is our highest ward
where we've got the highest number of
ehe so that's something that we monitor
on our dashboard we actually hold it at
school level detail as well and and from
a school improvement perspective if
we've got any schools where we're seeing
higher numbers of ehe we actually
challenge schools around that even
though we know it's a parental decision
we just want to check well why you know
why are parents wanting to electively
home educate is something going on in
terms of breakdown of relationship with
school or something so were there any
outliers we will challenge schools
around that too
there you can see the breakdown of
school years across that bar chart on
the left so you can see it kind of
fluctuates but those higher numbers are
seen in year five year seven year eight
and year ten
and that tends to be where where we see
those significantly higher numbers
and then there you can see the reasons
so we never used to have covid
we now have a bar for covid
so 37 there uh families electively home
educated for for covered reasons and
obviously that's very much around
anxiety and health concerns but the
biggest ones there are dissatisfaction
with the system
and that could be again relationship
breakdown uh it could be
you know it may link to all sorts of
things to do with education system or
also the school itself um but also
philosophical and ideological reasons
it's very difficult to pin it down
because we just kind of give a tick list
really because that's what we're
required to do i think we probably could
do a little bit more work to understand
what that actually means and what are
the choices for that and then
short-term intervention is another one
we do have
some children who are um scn as well uh
who do have an ehc um our numbers um at
the moment are quite low
um
i think i've got it actually on on a
spreadsheet it is relatively low it's
about seven children i think at the
moment um with an ehc who are electively
home educated and when i've looked at
the actual reasons for it a lot of it is
to deal with medical needs and to
address the scn needs at home
it's interesting the majority of them
have come out the specialist sector so
it's not as if it's even mainstream
going into ehe it's actually out of
special schools which is quite
interesting um what we do also do is
link in and monitor those who are known
to children social care as well um now
looking at the list again we've returned
a lot of those to education which shows
the effectiveness of the partnership
work with social workers in in really
promoting and advocating children
getting into education um i think that
we've just got one one child who
currently is known to children social
care who has been electively home
educated we also look at things like
gender breakdown as well um
etc and and it seems to be the majority
are female but it's only it's very
minimal in terms of the numbers
and the average age is around 11 11.41
years that's kind of the average age
there
the final bit really in the report was
the next steps because the government
has been clear that they want to
introduce the the register
which you know is is probably a positive
thing and will certainly help us to
really have a clear steer on the
position in the local authorities but
also create consistency which i think is
what what the government's um you know
is after
well
understanding that you know a lot of
families provide wonderful education for
children at home they really really do
but there is that requirement to
safeguard our children too
one final point before i do i do forget
we're really clear with parents as well
that when they do opt to electively home
educate they cannot get that same school
place back particularly because again
the pressures on our school places
system were really clear that actually
you may not get the school of your
choice if you do choose to return your
child to education so we have to be
manage those expectations too
so i think that's it i'll shut up for
now and open it up to questions thank
you
thanks karen and would you mind just
putting the lights back on so i can see
everybody thank you
and
so i'm going to ask um councillor
maitland did you have a question
thanks karen and just one of the on the
reasons and the refuse school refusal
yeah what's that about so
so really that is
it's i think we've got three children
i'm sorry um it is those children who
cannot attend school for it could be
mental health reasons um they just have
a real anxiety about attending school
is the school refusing them i wasn't
quite sure no okay oh no they wouldn't
be allowed to do that
no it's a really good question and we do
you know we do have a cohort of young
people who are anxious about attending
school what we try to do is refer them
through our medical education panel so
that they can attend our medical
education service the mez
and that's really helpful in trying to
support these children you know back
into school for those who genuinely
struggle with with school-based anxiety
council hornby
thank you i just uh thanks that was
really interesting really good to see i
was just wondering what our home
education figures look like compared to
other boroughs
it's like to say i i think ours are
are very comparable um when when we
looked at the increase certainly in in
the numbers um ours was probably one of
the lowest and probably still remains
you know one of the lowest we're not the
lowest in gm by any by any uh stretch of
the imagination um but
you know there are those that are far
far higher
um but i can certainly get a bit more
detail on that and ask the team to
produce a you know an analysis certainly
thanks karen i'm i'm actually very
surprised that there aren't a lot more
families decided to do this having
enjoyed it or been successful
um surprisingly there's what an extra 18
really which isn't a lot yeah
this is a great report it's really very
very interesting um
[Music]
is there any indication that those
children or young people who have been
home educated for for a long time um
have any issues if getting into
either further or higher education
later if they've not
been educated with
a greater number of of children or young
people i think that that is a really
good question and i was having a
conversation with the team actually
about that because
what what the team was saying part of
the the remit of the questionnaire and
the survey that we asked parents to to
um populate and share with us it's it's
showing that these children won't be
disadvantaged when they return to
education and that they're not
disadvantaged or if they want to go into
further education or even employment
because that's absolutely what what we
don't want so we do link them up with
connections advisors as well with
careers advisors
so that's something that we sign post
our families to to to support the the
children and the young people
um i don't have any hardcore evidence
about you know those destinations if you
like uh of our ehe cohort but that
that's an interesting piece of work that
i could certainly certainly take back
no
just secondly um
if
if the family
choose
not to
enroll their child
to an exam
and exams aren't taken
um
[Music]
i'm just sort of wondering how
how how is a child's education and
obviously it's not just an exam
pass or a certain grade that that sort
of highlights what this young person has
become at you know the end of that that
home school period but how how is an
assessment done as to how
a child has
learnt or not learnt during that period
of time
if the child doesn't sit the exam then
that is really up to the the parent to
determine really be because that that's
one of the things we ask about how
they'll evaluate the learning and how
you know not market but but kind of get
a sense check of how how the child is
progressing
as an authority yeah
you know if because
you know we all want our
children young people to to to do the
very very best that they can do yeah and
and have the help and support but you
know i'm just wondering you know are
there
are there any
of our young people that are sort of you
know
going under the radar um that
maybe
that they could have had more help but
they
maybe the parents weren't
sufficiently
able to give them that i'm just it's
just just a concern
and i think that's it's a really
legitimate concern because as i say it's
it's difficult because the regulations
mean that
you know we don't need to have that
level of rigor um all we need to be can
because the
children don't even have to follow the
national curriculum they don't have to
you know fulfill the hours of the day
that a child would in a school so
um we just need to be convinced that
you know the education that is being
provided is deemed suitable within the
guidance that the dfe provides um we
will absolutely make sure
parents are informed of the
opportunities to go into exams to try
and get some level of accreditation or
some some kind of results and as i say
we do link them in with careers advisors
as well who again may be able to support
them in terms of their next steps but
again you know it's
without that level of rigor in the
regulations it is quite difficult to
monitor now whether this new register
and so on may end up moving to a more
consistent approach i think it's be
interesting to see how that plays out
good question just lastly um
safeguarding yeah do do we have an
assurance that that our children young
people there's this adequate
safeguarding because as a you know yeah
thai teacher you know you
you see things that
a child will bring into school you know
whether or not it's domestic violence or
you know any any other fears and if it's
if it's the parent that is educating the
child
outsiders on a regular basis aren't
going to see that
absolutely and i think again this is the
premise for the new register that's been
introduced by the government is again to
try and get
to make sure that these children do not
go under the radar um the part where if
if there are any concerns if there are
any inklings i mean you know
particularly first of all those children
who may be known to to children social
care then obviously you know we can have
eyes on those children who are being
home educated because
they've got a link with with with
children's social care um if there are
any issues around suitability and we're
really concerned about the information
that is coming back either it isn't
coming back or actually the quality of
information that is coming back and home
visits do take place
and as to say we do link in with with
the front door as well to escalate any
concerns around safeguarding i think the
other thing counselor blackburn that we
do is this reports that karen's
presented this evening we have come
regularly into
my
um directorate management team
performance meeting for all of the
reasons that you're saying you know
drilling down in terms of what does that
actually mean who is that and pamela do
your service know about them so we do
have a level of scrutiny through that
lens of
and
is this
helpful and beneficial to that child is
it a person a parent genuinely
exercising their right or is there
something else that we need to think
about so that gives just that extra
layer of scrutiny but as karen says if
there are any concerns it does get
referred in and
there is an offer of support as well i
think as well jill it was tested out
certainly throughout covert when we used
to meet with the regional schools
commissioner and and ofsted i think it's
also been tested out probably through um
either one of the monitoring visits or
part of the inspection jail so
um
you know as a local authority there are
there are opportunities for us to be
held account for for our processes too
when we have our full reinspection
listen um
educational vulnerable children
including those that are
educated
electively home educated put my teeth
back in is one of those areas of focus
and as karen says
last year we had a focus visit in which
we had a dedicated hmi inspector who did
drill down into our arrangements around
electively home educated children
thank you i have got on the um work
program actually the education of the
vulnerable home educated as well coming
up at a future meeting but council
duncan did you have a question
yeah hi karen thank you for allowing me
to ask a question
um
to become a teacher you need to be a
qualified teacher
now is there a minimum requirement
excuse me ignorance
for home teaching
now do schools have checks in place to
monitor this
and if our local schools
are having an increase in home teaching
um
does that school get flagged up at any
stage at all
thank you yeah that's good questions in
terms of qualifications no it it's you
know any parent can electively home
educate it could be a grandparent it
doesn't even have to be a you know mum
dad whoever
so again
because i suppose again they're not
required to follow a national curriculum
they're not it's not um
it's not trying to do what the school is
doing if you like it's it's a completely
different offer that parents have the
option to do
um
so schools aren't accountable for for
the quality of education provided at
home that's not their responsibility at
all um and i think as a i kind of said
earlier what what we we do monitor the
numbers of of ehu children um for each
school so that if we are concerned that
there's a higher number we have the
question to the school to say what's
contributed to this check they're also
not off rolling check that this isn't a
go-to place for our schools because
they're not happy with her with a
particular
situation with a child or family um but
most importantly if this is around
breakdown in relationships as well then
there's something else going on at the
school so where there are outliers we
absolutely will challenge the schools
thank you
councillor witten
yeah so thanks karen that's really
interesting i just wanted um to ask how
do we make sure that new arrivals into
the borough and particularly new
arrivals from abroad whose parents might
be choosing to home educate their
schools
how much to get their children uh known
to the system
that's that's uh that's a really um good
question i mean certainly
so any new arrivals we would obviously
ask the families to go through the
school admissions process to to get a
school place um for those who are are
new to trafford um we wouldn't
necessarily
um have the details on them because we
we've you know they're not on roll they
haven't been on roll anywhere at all um
details are obviously shared on our
website so we
you know we're really clear with
families what the expectation is if that
is their choice and this this is the
requirement and this is this is what we
expect them to do
um
so that you know that that is a good
point i think that's where again this
centralized register is really important
because you know that there will be some
families that that we're just not aware
of who are home educating
i think because in the report we
mentioned do you mention gypsy travel
aroma families yeah and that's a you
know that's a good group of the
population that we kind of understand
have some insights into i guess in terms
of sort of way of life etc yeah i just
think it might be interesting to kind of
would be good to kind of have some
insights you know kind of large influx
of people from hong kong for example
you know we need some sense of whether
those
children are arriving as part of those
families are all going into our
education system yeah so yeah i think
anything we can do to get some insights
into sort of what different communities
are doing and yeah and the options that
they're
they're choosing would be really helpful
no that's that's really yeah it's a
really good point something we can take
away
thank you that my question sort of
ties in with with the last one then it's
a slightly
delicate area i suppose but do our
officers ever encounter parents with a
taliban like attitude
um i've not been made aware of that we
do keep an eye on particularly um
unregistered provision or provisions
where
um you know we are concerned generally
about the quality of education where
children might be
um being taught if you like um so that
you know there is a focus on that but
i'm not aware from an ehe perspective of
of that situation uh myself um but again
i i can certainly you know take that
question away and and and and see what
the team say i'm quite happy that this
subject's not really yeah
i was wondering how to how to phrase the
question yeah but
um but
is there scope for
uh
children to slip through the net
i think you know we we were talking
about just then you know children who
who may be new to the authority one one
thing that we do do so with our children
missing in education which is some you
know probably ticks that box of those
children who are new to to the area um
we do have a panel that scrutinizes all
the data and the information around that
um and that will pull from all sorts of
different sources whether that's census
details etc etc um so that is an
opportunity to really unpick um any
children that
we are concerned might fall through the
net and we either take them through fap
just to get them uh a school place or or
you know other processes may apply um
but i think
that that's the whole rationale suppose
for this new register that you know
there there is potential for you know
unfortunately that to happen but with
the new regis registration and with that
consistency of process the idea is that
that we we do have to be notified where
children are being home educated and we
hold that central register
if she's coming
in terms of every local authority there
is a duty on local authorities to have
um arrangements in place to prevent
radicalization for example so we have a
prevent panel we have a channel panel so
there are mechanisms in place if there
was a concern identified
about um radicalization for that to be
looked at if that's part of of the
safeguarding question
yeah obviously that's very very
important area i was more coming at it
from the
um
a parental approach of actually
depriving
the child of an education because of
their gender
yeah that's that sort of
uh thing and whether
you know
that is you know happening under our
very eyes
yeah
i mean with sort of building on what you
were saying jill anyone can put in a
referral to prevent it doesn't have to
come from a school a professional it
could be anybody that could do a
referral so i suppose from a community
basis that that could be referred in and
then that would would follow through
those processes um but i suppose again
it goes back to the suitability of
education and that that will come
through the scrutiny of the
questionnaire and the survey that we
share with families
that's an interesting question yeah
thank you councillor acton
yeah mine's very similar to graham's um
question i think
around travellers
particularly
you know in the very name of travelers
they're transition
and
they do move around and
um
and i just wonder how you
uh can monitor that situation and
whether the children
you know are getting an education and
you know i don't think um
you know you hear that they you know
some of the travelers children are
working here
when they should be at school yeah yeah
yeah we try certainly through the team
um
we we used to have an officer that was
kind of dedicated to
you know to
oh everything around some of our um
minority groups as well as our
our our traveler groups as well um and
you know they built up quite a good
relationship with the travelling
community as well
um
one of our officers
does have a relationship um they they
will visit sites um just to really kind
of you know promote the value of
education and so on and so forth so and
that is something that you know that
that we we have done um just with
capacity it's a challenge to do that on
you know on a regular basis
um but it you know it is about
relationships and that promotion of
education yeah
thank you
and counselor wells
thank you um yeah i'm aware that the
home education community is a very broad
church there's all sorts of people doing
it for all sorts of reasons and i know
from um councillor coggins my green
party colleague in austria she home
educates her child and i know that
there's there's network there you know
there's networks amongst a lot of the
parents and they they help each other
out and things like that
just wondering how aware you are of
those networks and do they you know
is there any interaction between
you guys and those networks and also at
what point you know
how formal do these networks be at what
point do they become offsteadable if you
see what i mean if they become so formal
that you know that
that they qualify for inspection
themselves i'd be interested to hear
yeah i i think no unfortunately there's
kind of again no necessarily that that
kind of um
rigorous monitoring and accountability
that that's kind of wrapped around some
of the networks um
we hold network meetings as well from a
trafford perspective and that's really
helpful to to try and get a sense of the
audience really the families the parents
but also
you know find out what kind of different
links and different groups that they've
set up so there is an opportunity
certainly for us to engage as a local
authority into these individual networks
as well as kind of running our own and
inviting families to those networks too
but yet in terms of that monitoring
that's not something that is
we can do um
it's it's certainly not within the
regulations to do
thank you so much well that was the
final item that i've got one more item
on the agenda which would be the work
program um
for the year we have got a few i know i
met with um jill a few weeks ago um
council blackburn and myself and with um
councillor new as the lead member for
education and also um with council hines
the um
executive member for children's
i've had one or two suggestions put
forward which we have incorporated into
this i know councilor welts and you had
some ideas that
we might look to discuss i'm very open
to anything if it affects our children
our young people please do if it's it's
a concern if it's something that
residents have contacted you about
please do bring it to this committee and
we can have a look for you
so do you want to start with your
friend
the first uh item um
is uh regarding um bike ability um
provision in the borough which seems to
have hit a bit of a wall over the last
couple of years
uh it's been a um
our year sixes last year of primary
school traditionally they have bike
ability training um and
uh
two years in covid's um virtually most
kids didn't didn't get it for
understandable reasons hence i proposed
the motion
council last year um you know
requesting that the council organizes
catch-up training for those kids who are
now in year seven and eight and there
has been a little bit of progress on
that um
an external provider has been appointed
and they are you know and they're now
contacting schools to try and you know
to get that rolled out across schools
across the borough um it does need uh it
does need
to be proactively promoted because
obviously you know head secondary school
heads are not used to
not used to doing this
what i have found out recently and this
is because my daughter is in year six
and her bike ability was recently
cancelled um
is i just discovered that it's actually
basically not happening at the moment
for the current year sixes and this is a
real concern it's basically the
provision has fallen apart as far as i
can tell
um it's it's
under one trafford's
um
responsibility um with the road safety
team um what seems to have happened and
i've spoken to some um to some
uh
former rights and bike instructors that
used to work for the you know for the
council providing the bike ability is
that the you know the terms and
conditions that that one trafford were
you know willing to offer were
substantially reduced the number of
hours and that kind of thing were
reduced and basically that the pool of
talent in terms of the in terms of the
um
uh trainers has uh has you know
evaporated so in so one traffic does not
have a pool of people to be able to send
around to the schools so they really
don't they don't have a provider
and
also
they've not been you know the schools
have been contacting them trying to get
the bike really provision but there's
been a very poor service in terms of
getting back schools are saying that
they've been um you know they've been
calling time and time again and that
nobody's been getting back to them so
hence i've discovered recently in my
local sorry in my local area that the
the at least i haven't spoken to all the
schools but at least six schools heads
have got in touch with me when they
realize what you know that i was you
know dealing with this
that
um
uh that they've missed out and i've been
and i've heard from from head
subsequently that that is reflected
across the borough sorry
i was just going to say that's really
interesting to know could we maybe if we
were going to look at something like
that broaden it into something to do
like active travel to schools or
something just a bit slightly wider in
scope
yeah let me look looking at that
specifically but also like yes so
there's that fundamental i mean it may
be quite an easy issue to tackle which
is good we should be quite good to have
something we can actually actually sort
out i think there's a there's a question
for bike invitability itself whether
it's
being handled in the right part of the
council are amy an organization that is
responsible for potholes and beam
collections are they the best people to
be organizing a multi into you know a
multi-school training
you know training program or should it
be handled elsewhere you know is it
something that should be handled i think
that's like a contractual question as
well though isn't it that it's not yeah
would this come under your remitters
under the schools or i think it probably
is kind of cross service just because as
you say the contractual arrangements
what we do have is safety around the
school gates group which and i'm not
sure whether that would kind of pick up
some of the active travel stroke you
know everything around kind of um
you know help help healthy uh sort of
all of those sorts of things really um
active travel et cetera i don't know
whether we could do something as as
broad as that just a report from the
safety around the school gates group
i would suggest chair that
what's being said basically i think we
should just ask the question first and
foremost
where are we up to with bikeability and
and if we get a report
uh
with regard to that then we could have a
spin-off in terms of
uh scrutinizing if necessary yeah i'm
just thinking for that
you know you've identified source of
year six and now
due to covert years seven and eight have
missed out on that
i presume it would be this term in and
perhaps the autumn term in which
that training would take place i'm going
back a long time when my children did it
it was a cycling proficiency
um but it tended to happen over the
summer and um i think autumn terms but
maybe if we could find out first ask for
a report on
what's happening with it where's it up
to why are we so behind and what's being
done to catch up i'm concerned that you
know in an ideal world
secondary school children
should be able to cycle to school and if
they've missed that training in in year
six um
you know we all know our roads are much
busier and more dangerous for them but i
think it's a basic thing really so
yeah
i appreciate that and i think that's a
really good place to start is getting
the report then let's let's hear how
many schools had it in the last year if
if i'm right and it's very very few then
we know that we've got a you know a
basic problem of delivery which
hopefully is something that we can
tackle quite easily there is a wider
point with bikeability and that is that
bike ability itself has uh i mean has
has been the organization has
restructured itself they're now offering
a much broader program um of bike
ability is basically they've got now got
bike ability one two and three which
goes much more through the school um you
know rather than it just being a one-off
thing that you do in years in year six
and that's the only bike training you
get for your whole life and actually it
can actually leave a lot of people
behind because
the bike ability that people get in
school relies on them and beyond to ride
already there isn't time in that
few hours of training to teach people to
ride a bike if they can't already
already ride a bike
um
so are they also bikeability now
officers one two three but they also
offer a um
a balance program as well which is aimed
at much younger children so looking at
kind of getting kids on balance bikes in
school age four and age four and five so
by the time they come to to be year six
you've got the entire of the school able
to participate in in bike ability rather
than it being an elective thing and then
again in
and then then the bike ability three is
in secondary school and that is very
much
focused on
developing the independence of the
riders help with route planning which is
absolutely fantastic for you know for
creating creating um you know
giving kids independence and safe riding
skills but also tackling it's at that
moment where i mean you see i mean we
all see it on the uh you know you get
some right some kids who they
ride confidently but they don't rest
their ride safely you know and and and
this is it seems to me if you know
rather than have a debate about it we
need to know
from officers where we're where we're up
to in the first instance and then we can
have the debate yeah so that would be my
alex is that something we can find out
who who's responsible
where we're at with it and request a
report on it initially and
see
if that could perhaps come to the next
meeting
uh yes i'll uh well we'll uh send an
email to uh
uh
until like uh it'd be under richard rowe
if it's to do with uh the one traffic
partnership so we'll send an email and
see if that date is available for the
next meeting do you say in september
yeah if that's so great that's great
thank you very much
thank you
has anybody else got any
topic ideas graham sorry absolutely a
couple of things you want one more
specific to start off with really i
think be really good to get a report on
take up of um child care support in the
borough and i mean that in its fullest
sense so take up of the childcare
support you get through universal credit
take above the three hours offer and
take up of uh tax fuel tax-free child
care for off parents which is
um
where there's a report relatively
recently talking about how under
subscribed that is nationally um and
obviously at a time when people are
struggling financially it's important
that um parents are getting as much
financial support as possible to deal
with child care costs a report on that
would be really good just so we've got
evidence as a committee and then we can
um have a think if if we want to do some
work on how we drive up
take up of those different types of
support
and then the other thing is probably a
bit more general and probably not got
this as fully thought through in my head
yet really but i think it'd be good to
get
a report on um
it's because we have had a large number
of new arrivals from particular and
parts of the world
in trafford over the last year or two
and i do think it would be good to get
some insights into the experiences of
children young people from those
um from those parts of the world so we
can kind of understand what their
experiences are like and what's
happening
and because i think i i'm just thinking
about the conversation we have started
in respect of the
um home educated children and sort of
the gap of knowledge there
um
you know i i feel that as a committee
it'd be good for us to get some
understanding and reassurances um around
kind of the experiences of children
young people from whether it's hong kong
afghanistan ukraine or wherever
yeah i think both of those are really
good um suggestions um
we have sort of set a rough agenda for
september would you be happy for those
to go on the november
yeah i think on the on childcare one i
think we could probably get a report on
that quickly that's the only thing
denise it'd be a shame
to not get that
soon rather than later and the other
thing yeah perhaps i could go on the
november agenda but it'd be good to get
that that sort of data on the sort of
uh the child care support take up
quickly i think because that's then
going to instigate whether well that
will determine whether it instigates you
know a bit of action further action from
the committee okay yeah i think it might
be interesting as well to come back to
that in six months time
when the energy crisis and everything
else has hit um
i think we're going to see a lot more
families falling into um
the poverty level and so be interesting
something to monitor moving forward
does anybody else have anything else
this is a sort of a rolling so i'm
always happy obviously if something
happens that we feel we need to jump on
straight away then that's fair enough
but i know that anything else council
welter yeah thank you um yeah this may
be covered elsewhere in in the program
um
it's just i mean the squeeze on
secondary school places in the uh
particularly in the south of the borough
got that on the set
yeah i thought i thought you might but
that's obviously you know obviously
thank you very much
look forward to
dealing with them yes
okay
well with that thank you everybody for
coming um i managed to keep within the
two hours on a fairly heavy agenda thank
you so much to our officers and our new
lead member for education
um
and i wish you all a safe journey home
it's nice to see everybody face to face
again
thank you